there's buildings and trees in the uk
that are older than your country it's
true but when you ask a british person
about the building or the tree they'll
lie to you about it you know i live in
east london half of it wasn't destroyed
by the germans like the locals will tell
you the locals from essex will tell you
the truth is the british pulled it all
down because they can't stand the side
of anything that's more than 50 years
old because they're so ashamed of it
i've been lied to about the age of the
building i live in in london so many
times it was from the 1930s from the
1880s it's from the
it's all been 1950s up at least our
history is new enough that we can't fake
it
tomorrow is my first thanksgiving
yes ever i don't know i don't know what
it is i don't know why you celebrate it
i don't know what to expect all that i
see are memes about how to insult or
have difficult conversations with your
family members around the dinner table
so can you give me
a guide for how to survive thanksgiving
please
well it's an adult outing
now i don't mean just leaving your house
and going outdoors i mean outing
yourself to your family in all sorts of
ways politically
in terms of sexuality and gender too
there'll be a lot of trans exploration
at thanksgiving this year because
everyone's trans there's millions of
them so we gotta look out they're there
there's one at the table so yeah there's
lots of trans so expect to transit your
thanksgiving it's transgiving this year
by the way is what we're calling it
transgiving by the way
um
yeah uh people um kill animals and
barbecue them and then eat them and try
to avoid
with their mouth full of food talking to
their family members i sit at the dining
table across my dad and wait for him to
take his last breath
so i don't have to do stand live anymore
because that old [ __ ] has so much
money will not spend it on me but yes
what it mostly is
is a chance for people to get together
and pretend it's not christmas around
the corner so there's no gifts there's
just food you shove it in you pass out
near the dining table and then you wake
up an hour late you said i gotta go i'm
so full you drive home that's what it is
or you fall down on the floor you're so
you're so full you lay down in your
brother's living room floor and wait for
people to pass by so you look up their
skirts but you don't really want to see
most of it so yeah it's that there's
that there's skirt
viewing but it's mostly just a time i
think
it's four day holiday
it's a shopping season because black
friday happens on the friday after chris
after thanksgiving so that's what people
are really most looking forward to i
like thanksgiving because halloween's my
favorite uh
best of holiday but thanks to myself
because it's just about the food and you
have to worry about gift giving yet and
i like the food it's a night turkey's
nice
some people have ham
communists eat pheasant or fish
or lobster which is [ __ ] up but a lot
of people do that where you're from i'm
sure there's a lot of uh
meat on the offer because texans love
their barbecue and barbecue turkey is
good
um
yeah it's about it's a holiday about um
responding to how lucky we are to have
escaped
uh european dominance people people left
europe in the 18th that well the 16th
17th century to for um religious freedom
and um
that's what they're celebrating they
said thank you god that we don't have to
uh eat with the english anymore is that
why and i've now been invited so it's
basically a victory party for your
nation over my nation
and i've been invited back around yes
they're going to kill you
so is this going to be like that get out
movie where that they invite that one
black guy around and then it's a big
game where they'll try and kill him
yeah
it'll be like that i mean i you know i
think people have forgotten the the uh
the truth about the holiday season which
really was um
some people came from europe
and took away some land from some
indigenous people
killed them with disease
or uh murdered all their children to
make sure they couldn't populate and
then
celebrated that
so we're trying to i'm not
celebrate the truth but this is where
the critical race theory comes in i
think people kids don't really
understand what the holiday season's
about because it'll ruin their
stuffing and their cranberry sauce
and where all that comes from i don't
know don't ask me where the cranberry
sauce comes from again that's an english
thing isn't it yeah very much so yeah
but i think it what i used to like about
the holidays too thanksgiving christmas
is these open films on these days in
america all the cinemas we open and i go
to movies with my family it was really
fun
but that's kind of not happening this
year either i think could have coveted
does anyone go to the movies anymore i
think anyone does man i don't know i
went to go and see what was the last
movie i went to go and see i can't even
remember i wanted to go and see the
james bond the new james bond and then
someone told me that it was terrible so
i didn't bother to go and see that i
wanted to see some new marvel thing yeah
it was empty absolutely yeah
i mean we're watching a mexican soap
opera tomorrow all day i think it's
hilarious called the house of flowers
it's so funny
and my husband's brazilian so he's a big
fan of mexican tv
and uh
some of my relatives are mexican
and
they're indigenous people as well
so
when i see them we don't really talk
much about the joy of thanksgiving and
they tend to bring pre-made packaged
microwave food to their festive events
yeah is that do you think that's a
little bit of a slight on the holiday at
large it might be yeah yeah it might be
but it's a big deal to my husband
because he believes in oh he's gone he
believes in family it's weird it's
[ __ ] up he just saw some of his family
in ecuador because he wanted to it's so
weird to me like he sees them out of joy
and happiness and union a bond
it's not out of obligation
yeah it's yeah or because you want a new
car because you want to brag about what
you make for a living so we're seeing my
family tomorrow
we've been harassed and kidnapped
basically emotionally so we have to go
see them
for a few hours he'll complain in the
car all the way there but it's mostly
because he doesn't understand why
there's a room full of people who hate
each other so much when he first met my
family he's like i've never been around
much in a room full of people who
clearly could barely stand the smell or
stench of each other i'm like well happy
christmas i mean my the nice people my
family died because they were nice they
were murdered so now it's just it's the
gangsters of the mafia left i mean
if we survive i'll be happy italians all
sit that my family will not sit with
their backs to the windows because
they're too afraid of being shot from
outdoors my father his whole house only
has windows on one side that's why he
bought it
he never goes to restaurants with
windows in them and he never pays with
credit cards he's too afraid of being
traced this is the mood i share
thanksgiving with my family in there why
are they part of the sicilian mafia yeah
they're illegal importers and extra
exporters that's how they made their
money it's all
it's all public with my family they
don't they're not ashamed of it they're
proud of it since the sopranos they're
like local celebrities in small towns
where they live jesus that's why they
wear a black tie on holidays it's weird
but they do it they wear black ties and
black jackets because they want everyone
to know who they are
wow they're they're muscle people it's
scary i can imagine you fitting right in
with a bunch of murderers and hitmen and
extortionists no they like the gay thing
because because they're because they're
comfortable leaving us alone with their
wives while they go go outside and smoke
marijuana in the driveway because they
know we won't hit on anybody they do we
can go shopping with their wives they're
fine with that we're like we're like gay
bodyguards right honey
yeah or they love it when we're there
because my husband's great with kids so
they leave their meatloafs alone with my
husband and he builds a fake bar for
them makes little drinks in like little
grown-ups and you know they go make
phone calls and deal drugs
internationally and they they come back
two hours later like can you bring him
to the next step because they don't like
their kids either they [ __ ] hate
their kids most people do
and people use it seems like a lot of my
buddies that are more personally
development inclined are using this as
an opportunity to do an end-of-year
review to kind of gratitude and such
that would be something typically that
we would do around new year's eve in the
uk
is that do people not use it as a time
to reflect the thanksgiving the
gratitude thing you know it's it's
really sweet only worldly view to say
but we're all about moving forward like
i said earlier we've got a world to run
here in the us so it's move move move
fast fast out of my way in fact half the
people
i see family functions or even in clubs
or bars when i'm working are on their
phones all the time buying and selling
this country's about uh modern not the
past
in fact well that's because you don't
have any past there's there's buildings
and trees in the uk that are older than
your country
it's true but when you ask a british
person about the building or the tree
they'll lie to you about it that's the
thing about the british they've got to
pass
but it's made up i mean every you know i
live in east london and half of it
wasn't destroyed by the germans like the
locals will tell you and you know the
locals from essex will tell you what the
truth is the british pulled it all down
because they can't stand the side of
anything that's more than 50 years old
because they're so ashamed of it i've
been lied to about the age of the
building i live in in london so many
times we've had so many of us from the
1930s from the 1880s it's from the 1950s
where the [ __ ] is that nobody knows it's
all been made up
at least our history is new enough that
we can't fake it i mean i know what you
mean i mean in austin there should be
quite a history
um but again i think they tear
everything down and
which i mean in a way a lot of my
british friends come here what they like
so much about it is how new
and clean everything seems to be except
in san francisco i mean we have a real
homeless problem here
that people tend to ignore and dismiss
because it's the wealth it's both the
wealthiest and the poorest
part of the us where i live here there
was a man walking so in america there
are these lanes at least in texas there
are these lanes in the middle of the
street and they're ones that are used by
people that are going to turn left or
right and they're like feeder lanes or
turning lanes or something and um
when i go down south lamar in austin
that street
always has around about every 500 meters
or so a homeless person walking along
with a with a little cardboard sign and
that makes me sad but then
twice now
in 10 days i've been here i've seen
somebody who is naked a homeless person
who is naked with a sign but only naked
from the waist down
oh right so fully dressed up top with a
bag
but then one lady who had her vagina out
and then one gentleman who was just
fully swinging in the wind and uh
i just
i think that's hard to ignore i don't
know how you mentioned that people in
san francisco can ignore the homeless
problem it was difficult for me to
ignore the ladies vagina
well that's that's uh but not the
swinging penis thought you're you're
you're that's just part of the course
you know yeah yeah of course yeah
um you know i think that's why they're
doing it because they feel ignored
um and the winter's coming up
but i i also
yes
in fact i'm surprised they were just
standing on your island we call them
islands
um and the islands here in california
they're living
and they're in the middle of the road
they're raising children yeah it's it
can be very
difficult
yes so um
when you're trying to make a left when
you're trying to make a left turn down
at 46th or something yeah yeah yeah and
there's someone that's you know they're
they're frying they're a family of five
in the way seriously it it's you know
when i i've been in india a few times
for work and you do see people on the
street there who have been living there
for generations that's their corner
um and it's becoming it's on that way
here in the us and it's the disparity of
wealth
that creates
such a such a
a
disportionate
population i don't i'm a bit i it's not
just a shame that i feel i mean of
course i feel
ashamed that i live in a culture and in
a planet that lets that happen but it's
it's it's a it's a confusion i have
because i'm not quite sure why i live in
a place i live very close to silicon
basically silicon valley where i live
and i i work and live with people
who are making millions billions a house
just sold near us for 1.5 million
dollars over the asking price 1.5
million
over what they're asking so that's the
kind of money that you see here right
so why these people can make that kind
of money creating an app
that allows them to get a pizza and the
taxi on the way home but
which is genius great for them but they
can't use that you know
harvard graduation
uh
promise of cleaning up the world to
[ __ ] fix the biggest problem that's
on their doorstep that they [ __ ] to
their families about all the time oh
someone's in my doorstep and they're
[ __ ] on my car they've got a needle
in my in their arm well then fix it
fix it how about paying your taxes
or what i don't get is why it's we're
all part of the problem we're you and i
are doing it right now we're on skype
why we're using
social media to celebrate
how great we each of us are
to discuss our own egos on this podcast
for 60 minutes but
but we don't see a skype
opera house or a facebook cinema or an
amazon
homeless shelter ever
ever
these companies are here because they
get tax breaks they don't pay anything
i'm going on and on about this but i
don't unders i i i i understand as much
as you do the whole problem
it certainly seems to be a little bit
different in the us as it is in the uk
there's
i don't know in the u.s maybe it's
because of the weather
that people can't settle as much in the
uk or maybe it's that there's fewer
fewer of them or maybe just the culture
the subculture of homeless people's
differences
do my husband's from brazil from here us
living in london we know that i mean i
know the statements being dismantled by
the by by you know bj i know that's
happening but in the meantime
you at least have some there's you know
behind our house in london there's a
ex-prostitute i know that because she
used to chase me down the street this is
going into my house i'm like honey
you're you're barking up the wrong elm
seriously
uh i don't pay for it and i don't pay
for [ __ ] especially that's just my but
but she was quite aggressive and now she
lives behind us with her husband one of
her jobs who she married and she has
three kids that she's raising with him
and we see that and we know they're
dealing drugs out of their kitchen
window which they're gonna have to to
pay for their car but at least they have
a place to live
right she's raising three they might you
know
she's got a family and that i just it's
not gonna happen here yeah you're gonna
lose the house because you have a
medical
problem
you know i
and you're not aware of it and you
shouldn't be you shouldn't have to be
but you've been raised in a country with
free healthcare and you cannot even
imagine
how much lighter that makes your life
when my mother died of advanced lung
disease we found a stack of bills on her
desk she was dealing with insurance
companies until the [ __ ] day she fell
asleep and died in her sleep
trying to pay off bills so she could
breathe and if you don't have that in
your life you don't just live longer you
don't lose your house
it's not just not having nationalized
health care does feel very barbaric
coming from a country that has
yes you don't even think about it i
remember i went to new orleans on a road
trip a couple of years ago and the guy
that did the tour was very capable it
was one of these wiccan
dracula scary evening tour things and up
here the ghost of whatever and it was
cool and you got to drink so it made it
all seem a bit more believable and this
guy was real competent really really
competent big tour company he was doing
it for we tipped him at the end and we
were like we want to go up some beers he
said oh well i also work as a barman at
this place i'm like hang on so you do
your tour guide of this thing and also
you help the operator and you're doing
the bar okay cool we'll go to the bar
with you start chatting to him and he
was we were talking about this
conversation and he said if you get hit
by a car you'd better walk it off
because if somebody calls the ambulance
to come and pick you up that can
bankrupt you that can send you into this
cycle of debt that you're now stuck in
yeah
yeah
and that scared me this guy's real hard
working you know
two three maybe more jobs he was saying
i've got two cracked teeth at the back
but i'm not i can't pay to get them
fixed and i'm not going to get the
insurance or whatever to do the thing
i'm like this is [ __ ] medieval [ __ ]
what's going on
yes and then it
it and that continues like you said you
know until
maybe he injures himself
a friend of mine
is a psychiatrist at a kaiser hospital
which is a huge local hospital
and he's dealing with um
people with drug addiction
and these are people that have jobs that
can't quit
so he tries to get them off the heroin
in the crystal
and they've been taking pain medication
some of them their entire adult lives
because they injured when they're at
university playing sport or something
and they can't stop working
they can't take a week or two or four or
they can't go to rehab they'll lose
their jobs and losing house it's really
vicious you know
i mean edson my husband and i we're so
lucky because we aren't caught up in any
of this cycle
is that fundamentally fueled by the
medical problem where does this come
from because you know outside of that i
don't see why america is any more
expensive of a place to live than
anywhere else right i mean i think
that's
it's a complicated situation where
people
were certain language is used to
discourage people from socialized
healthcare like the word socialism i
don't know why scares a lot of people
here although they get their social
security checks every month but they
don't understand the similarity or the
difference
and and i think that people are worried
about the you know we've heard about
death panels where hospitals decide
whether or not you live or die
which frankly does happen in the uk
sometimes but you know it's not a common
occurrence and if people here would just
look at the way the pandemic's been
handled by the nhs how brilliantly
they've handled how how they saved boris
johnson's [ __ ] political career you
know
what upsets me though it's not just that
too it's education i mean it just feels
like here
edson and i notice there's a lack of
empathy in the u.s there just is there
just is i and i mean yes nationally you
see it on television you see the way
people are dealt with socially here
locally you see it in our political
system nationally and locally
there is a feeling of you need to look
after yourself and take care of yourself
and
when we're in france
uh you know i had to live in italy for a
while to get my
my citizenship taken care of
when we're living when we when i stay in
australia for long periods working i
don't sense it there
i feel like
the people i know who live here and work
here do so because they want to make
money
and if you're not a part of that
vicious cycle then get out if you're not
in the economic engine yeah i think
one thing that i've definitely noticed
is that americans need far less at least
the americans that i've been around need
far less of an excuse to treat
themselves or to enjoy themselves i
think i'm seeing much less of a puritan
work ethic over here so you want to go
out on an evening time you go for some
food or whatever someone doesn't have to
earn the right to be able to go and do
that now that may be because i'm from
quite a working class salt of the earth
place in the uk and austin is kind of
every other person is a
crypto millionaire that i mean yeah
[ __ ] decentralized yeah musician that
does psychedelics on a weekend and
somehow sold their company for so maybe
that maybe it doesn't matter but um it
definitely feels like there's there's
more of a leisure culture here you know
people just say what you're doing at 2pm
we're going
out on the boat or
some [ __ ] like that's not
that's not the sort of thing that you
would see in the uk
yeah there's definitely uh uh
an idea
it depends on where you live for sure
but um
there's a feeling here that people do i
think that's why the pandemic people
struggle so much because i mean our
friends don't cook everybody goes out to
dinner at least at least five nights a
week people go out a lot and i think
they work hard and then they they they
like to play hard and in fact some young
people just moved to the building across
the street from us two you know so we
can see their entire lives because they
didn't bother buying curtains but they
party so
much and that's
really
great for them maybe a result of them
being cooped up for 18 months but also
there's there's a
a feeling of life moving quickly forward
that we really feel when we're here we
feel like our lives in london really
slowed down when we're there
especially over the last two years but
definitely because
yeah we feel like there's a lot more
people just go to a pub in the uk and
they talk and they
they hang out and there's less of a
feeling of having to be impressed
there's some i mean my husband's
brazilian he doesn't want to talk about
people's income he's totally embarrassed
when we go to functions here because
people go oh god about how important
they are and it's it's really it's
i i don't know i think people want to
feel
when they're here as if they're on the
forefront we are in a place
against silicon valley where a lot's
being created there's a there's more
wealth being generated here
in the bay area than in any any other
place in the history of the world
so we're living in that so he's still
got that sort of frontier mentality
but definitely but also because of
what's happening right now but
california has always been a gold rush
state things go up and down i think
maybe people here are a bit paranoid and
freaked out aware of that and everyone
knows a lot of people know that they're
one paycheck away from being homeless
themselves and the kind of stress that
that creates amongst people yeah
you know
i think people here feel trapped and
what i mean is they're in a job where
they're making a quarter million at
oracle to create a nap
um and there's a team down the hall
creating that same app and if you [ __ ]
up you're fired and then you they don't
just punish you they fire you that's the
contract you signed with satan who runs
oracle so now you're living out of your
car
in a beachfront community or all you can
afford is decaf coffee in the morning
and you don't know what you're going to
do with the kids
and you think oh you'll be welcome back
into the social media community soon you
get it but you're never welcome back you
lost the data you're out get the [ __ ]
out we don't even really want tourists
here because we can't afford them we
can't afford you because we're paying
for the homeless they cost a lot you
cost more protecting you from people
stealing your car or
banging down the window of the hotel you
stay in and taking all your luggage all
this shit's happening right now so we
can't afford to have visitors stay out
get out don't come back we don't want
your dollars i'll do my best i will i
will do my best but i want to talk about
um i spoke to
douglas murray about this a while ago
about the internal politics of the lgbt
group right and even calling it a group
is kind of dumb
what douglas brought up and i keep on
having this conversation because
austin's quite progressive right and
there's a bunch of different people in
there the fact that
the l's and the g's
actually have nothing in common like
they genuinely there is nothing that
those those two groups have everyone in
douglas's words is a bit suspicious of
the bees they're not really too sure
what they're doing there they don't
really know
they feel like they're l's or g's that
haven't really committed and then the
t's
in douglas's words are just working
against everyone so
has the last time i spoke about this was
maybe two years ago 18 months ago uh has
anything changed over the last 18 months
well we've added the eyes and the cues
what's the eyes
intersexual
what's that
i i don't really and we've added the um
i think it means you're what you're
whatever you say you are okay so that's
to do with gender expression and then
what's the cues a questioning
i thought you stood for queer
no
you're not meant to say that word at all
that's not for you that's like dropping
the in mom that's for us to say okay
unless you want to whisper in the game
and see why you're standing in line for
a drink in the game you can do that as a
question
yeah or hey queer get out of my way
yes and then there's a plus don't forget
the plus at the end everything else
everything because we're desperate for
conversation just dump any [ __ ] on the
pile he will take it we'll take anybody
right we're trying to expand
um we're branching out yes you know
i think it's all meant to seem inclusive
but there's two kinds of inclusive in my
head there's an inclusive where you
don't all agree and that's okay like a
table full of feminists
uh where they a true feminist believes
there's there's a seat for everyone at
that table
um or there's inclusive where you aren't
really which is these people who are
attacking
someone like the woman who wrote those
books for children where they have
dragons and you need blind not you need
lightning no the other one yeah her too
but um that was a race thing right
yeah the the
harry potter stuff the oh
jk rowling yeah yeah yeah who expressed
her opinion which is just her idea and
then she got
death threats so that's meant to be an
inclusive part of a society which is an
inclusive law and i think when you're
trying to it's like the u.s it's too big
i think the lgbtiq plus community is too
large i think you're right i think when
a lot of queers dropped dead from aids
in the 80s and the dykes were like we're
going to take over the gay pride event
in san francisco because we can do it
better a lot of queers are like you know
what maybe you can because we're busy
trying to count our t cells so go for it
see if you can do that
and um
and that's why they took the lead in the
parade on their bikes now stacks with
bikes for their parade but fine the
queers couldn't walk anymore anyway they
[ __ ] they couldn't move they were
they were dying
so
and they did pretty well although what
happened with the gay pride events
it was out of all of our hands anyway it
became commercialized so now
everything's so accepted and people
bring their little meatloafs in baby
carriages look at our babies and we're
buying beers we're heterosexuals we
support coors be now it's all about
product placement
which is what it was going to become
anyway
and that's what brings our community
together which is buying and selling
commercializing it
so it's not a community based on
you know uh community community
political thought or us banding together
to save a group or making things better
for certain people now it's just about
us showing off for a gap ad
which is i think what upsets people the
most i mean no one believes it bisexual
anyway but a bisexual levi's is even
less impressive than sorry a queer with
aids we were more politically savvy and
powerful when we were dying
and now that we're living
we're selling coca-cola and soap like
everybody else so i agree with you i
think the lgbtiq plus
is no longer necessary i just don't
think it is i think gay people are still
marginalized in certain communities i
think they are in certain communities in
the uk believe me on the comedy circuit
i don't always feel safe purely because
of my sexuality
but what do you mean when you say safe
i don't
feel
like
walking back to my hotel room
but on my own is necessarily a good idea
when i'm in stoke on trent
i just don't
but that might also be because of my
accent and in fact the first thing i
have to do to out myself that i'm on a
comedy stage anywhere in the world is
explain why i'm american and i can i'm
still allowed to tell jokes because
being americans would offends people i
don't find an audience that i have in a
long time who's offended by the gay
thing
it happens
so infrequently but what really gets
people going is my accent
oh they get they get antsy and incy
about that that's what i first have to
deal with
so
yeah i'm not really worried about the
gay thing anymore and i feel like you're
right the lesbian gay community probably
never had that much in common anyway
although i have to say
during the aids crisis the lesbians were
really there they really they really
stepped up
they stepped up in terms of volunteering
a lot because i worked in a lot of
volunteering communities in san
francisco
like the aids quilt for example the
lesbians really did a lot of admin on
that really a lot of admin because
they were prepared
and they were healthy
and they administratively minded
they were
you said it and they were valuable
to gay men and really helpful so in that
way that community bonded together but
again they came together because of of a
virus so maybe we should put
the idea that we're all the same aside
until we're in in a common battle with
something else um
speaking about jk rowling do you see
that she
had a photo taken outside of a house
recently you see this
yeah i read about it yeah jk rowling has
accused three people who campaign on
transgender matters of posting a photo
of her edinburgh address on twitter the
author who had been criticized for
reviews on trans issues has reported the
matter to police police scotland said
they had made been made aware and
inquiries were ongoing in a now deleted
social media post one of the groups said
the photo had been removed after they'd
received threatening messages online in
her own twitter thread rowling said that
the image depicted three activists in
front of her home carefully positioning
themselves to ensure that the address
was visible yes
so it's guerrilla warfare i think and i
think that she's probably got a security
system looking after her now she didn't
already
it's madness that you don't already i
mean the woman's worth
an unlimited amount of money
and that's probably why she felt she
needed one anyway and now she's probably
even more terrified
i mean you know the thing is
i
i'm not going to take a stance on what
she said i think she's her her opinions
are valuable they're hers
i don't i don't care i i still don't
i've never read her books i'm sure she's
a lovely person
um
but you don't want to know your what
your favorite author or actress or
thinks when i read a streisan interview
i was like oh my god she's out of her
[ __ ] mind how have i been obsessed
with her music for so long
barbara streisand has a museum below her
house in malibu
i'll repeat this a museum of herself
below her house this is documented
there's been a play written about it on
broadway
when you go to her house she might take
you on a tour below her house of the
seller of all her awards and things
about herself she's out of her gourd
when she talks about herself she does in
third person she's crazy but she's
barbara so i ignore all that
right if you read about certain actors
they're anti-semitic i remember reading
about an actor i will mention here who i
[ __ ] love an american actor
i've watched all of his films and he
said in a quote that the jews were in
hollywood so it's like well i guess i
can't watch your movies anymore
but i
do
i mean you know eddie murphy was a
famous homophobe in his in his first
video that one of those awards the
things he said about gay men were
horrible then i met him when i lived in
la waiting tables doing room service
i room serviced him on academy award
night three years in a row because he
wouldn't go to the academy awards he'd
watch him in his hotel room he's five
foot four he sits on a stool and he's
clearly homosexual he's a little gay and
tight pajamas i was 25 that hit on me
relentlessly but i did the room service
because it's eddie [ __ ] murphy
it's complicated isn't it he's a
brilliant comedian there are certain
things about people that make them
interesting and you and if that makes
them interesting you've also got to
sometimes ignore that
this is the problem that we've got with
social media facilitating everyone to
have an opinion and also everyone to
share that opinion yeah previously
previously you had to work to be able to
get a platform of the size where even if
you were an author you know if you
wanted to talk about your
either well-informed or ill-informed
opinion on whatever it was you still
needed to find an outlet it was through
a newspaper or on tv or whatever whereas
now the brain to fingers filter has been
completely removed and
millions and millions of people all over
the globe can see within seconds what
your brain just farted out and then you
decide to put it out there the world
isn't meant to consume everyone's
innermost monologue
in real time 24 hours a day
yes it's true and i think that it makes
people braver too uh to to
to shout and yell
and it makes them feel like they have a
bit of power when they felt so powerless
for so long
there's that too
and and everyone's this star of their
own video they're on they're on all the
facebook instagram whatever and they're
making moves about themselves all the
time tick tock i mean
and their movie their little
video might get you know eight million
hits and they feel like they feel like
now they have the power to say and feel
what they want
you know live
yeah i mean
in in a way i thought that the internet
as it progressed would make our lives
easier but it's made it
in fact more confrontational
the problem is i think that we we very
quickly went from a scarcity of
information to a surplus of information
in the space of probably
10 years so i think
the optimal amount of information that
we had on the internet was maybe like
2011 or something
there and then very very very quickly
you went from needing to be able to be
good at finding information on the
internet to being able to be good at
discerning signal from noise on the
internet yeah the best people the
smartest people that i know now are the
most discerning ones not the ones that
go the deepest they're the ones that are
able to cut through all of the [ __ ]
whereas yeah ten years ago when we had
that one day whatever it was november
the middle of november in 2011 that was
that was when we had the right amount of
information it was about i i thought it
was always going to be about shopping
i never thought it would become more
than that i just thought it'd be about
finding items online and purchasing them
because i have collectibles i won't show
you my husband
oh hates them so much in fact i was just
shopping for a
a mid-century ceramic
um coffee urn online before you and i
spoke in fact you interrupted that which
i'm sorry that's right i found one
though um but i thought that's what the
internet was gonna be it would never be
about
because i thought people liked i thought
people that were looking for mission
liked research and reading because it
turns out nobody does as it turns out
everyone wants things inactive
preferably
current like live images
i've seen so many images
live not live obviously but filmed of
that car hitting those poor people in
wisconsin
who wants to watch that image apparently
people want to watch
you know a journalist have his head cut
off in the middle east people
want to see the outrage pawn isn't it
i don't know so here's here's one thing
that i've been thinking about since i've
been out here so austin's got a big
psychedelic culture right which is
people trying to connect
as much as you can talk about like hippy
dippy [ __ ] um they're trying to
connect with two emotions that i think
we're really missing which is ore and
dread we don't often actually get to
experience ore and dread anymore and i
wonder whether
seeing uh feeling indignation
is kind of like an alternative for that
like i can't believe this happened it's
it's shock it's outrage it's indignation
i'm wondering whether people are
supplanting what previously the night
sky and some pretty nature would have
done for us to make us feel small and
insignificant or perhaps a trip to
church on a sunday to to you know feel
like we we are connected with the wider
universe i wonder whether that it takes
some of the same boxes i'm not sure so
you think social media is the new jesus
a little bit i think that
what it facilitates is um outrageous
videos that people can't believe have
happened and that emotion indignation's
not far away from dread and all
i don't think when you see something
that's completely shocking uh and i
wonder how much that's
supplanted it
like did they put one nail through his
feet or two
and people just
they can't imagine and they get somehow
turned on by it at the same point of
being horrified by it
you know
i i really feel like
because i still do i'm a dinosaur so i
still make my living in hospitality live
performance really i'm a babysitter as a
stand-up comic and i really feel
um
when i'm on stage like people expect
they expect something so vivid
and aggressive not from comedy
then when they don't get it
they're disappointed and i think that's
been driven by what you're describing
how do you mean vivid and aggressive
i have people say to me because i just
did a weekend at a mainstream club i did
five shows and three nights hour long
sets and i had people
asking me to cover certain subject
matter that i'm not going to cover on
stage i'm not going to talk about that
on stage i mean i don't have boundaries
about material i'll talk about anything
really
but i i people were like oh you didn't
push that far enough you talked about
that but you didn't push it far enough
like you know
and it's like look
everything's everything goes to the nth
degree now so quickly every subject
becomes explosive really quickly like
you know that woman who used to be fat
who's in fact anymore the british one
adele the
yeah the the chimney sweep who can with
five ranges
she um
she
was here with oprah and oprah kept
trying to go to her and she's like look
i can't
i've lost a bit of weight oprah's like
you've let so many people down so many
people are sad they're suicidal because
they're fat you're not anymore it's like
oprah jesus raided him and she kept
raining oprah in saying look i've got to
make a living i've got to deal with my
own [ __ ] she was very funny and live
past 70 as well hopefully
and she was very
it's just you know what
part of the reason why i started going
to the uk 25 years ago to do stand-up
was because um
the culture is less less
this vicious less savage than the u.s
culture
if that's the state there i didn't feel
like i mean i felt i came out in my
first show i did there in edinburgh but
it wasn't necessary for one thing look
at me but also the audience if you have
tails and a horn they don't care just be
funny the british they don't they're not
impressed or depressed by any of that i
mean like i said i don't feel always
safe in certain environments when i'm in
the uk
but that has very little to do with my
being on stage
and
i i've always felt here like i lived in
an explosive
situation
and people want comedians to figure [ __ ]
out for them sometimes
and now
you've got less time to figure stuff out
on stage people's they want it now they
want it faster they want it more
aggressive they want more brutal they
want it louder
even the fact that comedies become such
a big business and you see comics
performing at 10 000 seat arenas with
the head mic on screening at people for
an hour it's just become everything's
become
like i said nth
degree and the argument is no longer
like i used to feel like one of the
reasons why i preferred performing here
in the us in a way sometimes was i felt
like i could have more more of an
extended conversation about race and
politics here
but i don't feel that anymore here i
don't feel that do you not think that
immediately anyone who looks remotely
talented or has a platform gets co-opted
into trying to take a stand on something
so for instance we had the laurel
hubbard who was the new zealand
transgender weightlifter who competed at
the olympics and the other three women i
think it's the three women that she was
competing with for the uh that were most
likely a podium were asked in or it may
have been afterwards asked in a press
conference um what do you think
obviously this is an incredibly unique
opportunity you're witnessing history
unfold and there's a nine second pause
and then one of the girls just leans
forward presses the button to activate
her mic and goes
no thank you
and just turns the mic off and that that
to me was really reassuring so you think
these people are good at lifting heavy
things from the ground to over their
head they're not this isn't their role
stop looking at these [ __ ] athletes
like that's supposed to be i understand
i understand that if you are in a
position of
social gravitas if you have talent that
you can use your platform in order to
help uh push forward a particular
narrative because you have reach and
people respect what you do
but that should be the
anomalous case of the person who happens
to the you know the cassius clay
deciding not to go to vietnam thing
right like that that that's an anomaly
from history that's why it was so
interesting it shouldn't be that every
[ __ ] person with more than 10 000
followers on some social media
is now a platform and the reason for
this is that every political party is
trying to pick up whatever not point not
not not one percent of influence that
they can and just co-opt everybody in
yes this person decides to stand with us
or stand against us right
well i blame you know
i blame pontius pilate in a way
because he created jesus into the first
social media figure because mary sold
her son out because she wanted to be
famous as well
so it all happened then and people are
still paralleling their lives to that
they still think
i can win
you know
i i agree with you i mean i think when
comedians go on twitter and try to fight
a political
opinion
it's like just write a joke about it
you're not a political leader that's
your route that's your outlet your
outlet is to make this funny and do it
in a show
use your voice as a comic
but
you know everything's everything's a a
talent contest now and for a lot of
people
that
are wondering how they're going to make
a living or get famous or be rich if
they do a shocking video
that'll let you go there you go have you
you might have missed this because you
don't strike me as a joe rogan listener
but joe rogan had snoop dogg on his show
a couple of days ago and he brought up
that one of the reasons he thinks that
they
are getting people to focus on race is
the fact that it will distract us from
the fact that class is the real problem
of course
yeah always has been i mean you know
britain hides it
better
by denying exists but there's a an
ingrained class system there that the us
is embarrassed by because he tried to
break away from it when we left and it's
it's even more here
and here it seems based
externally you think it's based on
income but it's not there's there's an
opaque
one percent this country that not only
will i never meet i'll never even know
who they are
and they're running everything so
yeah there's a system here that
seems to
create
a group of people that really have have
no
again we talked about this they they
have no
empathy they have no reason
to you know when i if you've been
watching succession i know it's not a
documentary but i've worked for rich
people
uh many times for very very wealthy
people and they're [ __ ] miserable and
they take it out on each other and um my
family has a bit of money
based on
you know
investment and property and the way my
family treats one another is not that
dissimilar from what you're watching on
tv there's a lot of suspicion and threat
because no one wants to be knocked down
a pig
no one wants to go down a pig
and
man it's just here
oh there's so much and some of my
friends identified as homophobia here in
the us still it's not when you're when
people you know that are positions of
power to you that way it's class because
they think
if you've identified yourself
in a subculture like the lgbt community
in this country
that that's because you're a loser
and what they mean is that they
themselves might suck hog as a guy but
they don't but they would never identify
as being gay
because they don't see themselves as
politically motivated by that community
and they're winners they've been told
they're winners their whole lives they
went to yale them to graduate school
they have a phd they teach at stanford
they've got a wife they've got kids
because that's what a winner looks like
and to be gay to not have those things
to have your power reduced at that level
even and especially the educational
level of higher education normal in this
country
makes you a loser
it's a class system
it's not about being queer
it's about being a winner and if you
have black skin
it's not your fault
but i it identifies you in a certain way
and people associate things with you
which may be more media-driven than
anything else
but again it's not about race
it's about whether you're at the top or
bottom
literally did you see that the woman's
march group sent out an email with the
average number of donations recently and
the number was unfortunate you see this
well what do you mean unfortunately the
women's march group sent out an email
with average donations and apologized
for including 1492 in there we
apologized deeply for the email that was
sent today 1492 was our average donation
amount this week it was an oversight on
our part to not make the connection to a
year of colonization conquest and
genocide for indigenous people
especially before thanksgiving
it's not even the proper year they're
reading that from crappy history book
from their elementary school it's a
different year it's all made up
oh jesus
yes hilarious god that's funny that was
supposed to be the year that christopher
columbus had stepped on american soil he
did yeah it is that year or so he said
who knows
1492 so that number itself the average
amount of donations was problematic
yes and he might have been in other
parts of not the us but in america
before that other people were anyway yes
um yeah
that's that's something worth feeling
bad about but this is what i mean
comedians don't have to be non-funny
about this stuff or you know politically
motivated in some correct way there's so
much material that's one great thing
about all this that's why i miss trump a
little bit there's so many jokes in all
this i mean if you're not writing
material about this
then you are a loser i mean if you are
avoiding this stuff on stage it's one
thing i like about rogan you know i've
only worked with him once again i was
doing a weekend here in the city at the
same club i discussed earlier and he was
popping in and he wanted to do his own
show so he we closed my show and at
midnight he went on that same stage
because it's such a popular club i did
his own set and i watched him and i was
i was impressed how [ __ ] intelligent
he is live
and i i wish i i wish he trusted himself
enough on his own show not that i
listened to every podcast but i have
listened to it and i feel like he
dilutes it a little bit maybe just on
the ones i heard
but he is a brainiac he is and
and i do like that he covers current
subject matter in his sets and that he's
funny about them he may not agree with
what he says he may hate his politics
whatever but
all these people getting angry about
a recent comedy show on netflix where
the comedian went on about lgbt rights
and trans rights people just [ __ ]
lost their sum
quit their job or protested
over chappelle said i watched it it's
chappelle
he pushes the buttons he does what
chappelle does i wasn't offended in any
way by what he said about the lgd in
fact i thought he said something
brilliant about gay you know gay people
are liberal until they're white which is
true
can gay people be racist yes they can
we have a whole racist subculture in the
lgbt community that i won't go on about
right now but a lot of guys
what are you a rice queen are you a
sticky rice queen are you a brown wise
queen are you a dinge queen
all these terms meaning skin color about
who you're [ __ ] so yeah gay people
can be racist if you're wondering
and he covered it a lot of gay comics
wouldn't go near that in their eyes they
wouldn't be brave enough we have to wait
till chappelle does it right and then
complain about it
you know i feel bad like andrew said
andrew doyle who's your friend of ours
for all those people who had a gun held
to their heads and made to watch that
set on netflix you don't have to watch
it change the channel turn it off no one
cares about your [ __ ] opinion about
it you know if you're offended you're
good people are offended by comedy all
the time that's because it works
they're just ideas they're not going to
hurt you
didn't you get you got
in some trouble on australian tv for
doing something didn't you get cancelled
from australian tv basically never been
invited back because of that the entire
country of australia has a problem with
you
there's a myth about it now too there's
there's whole memes about it and there's
there's sayings don't capuro me on this
you're not gonna go pro us are you
meaning you're not gonna go on tv and do
a different set than you promised right
you're not gonna get people fired from
this network you're not gonna so the
story is that i told jokes about raping
the virgin mary now i didn't tell those
jokes do you have any because if you
have them and they're good i'll tell
them don't have them what i talked about
was christ being on the cross
and forgetting his safe word is what i
talked about but they had seen my
scripted set
and they had denied me a rehearsal i
won't defend myself in this i don't have
to
but what they did was change the story
after my set came out live on tv
to defend themselves now at the time
this is long this is 20 years ago i
would have used it to push the show
forward that's what i would have done
let's run with this but they were
cowards and didn't know how to do that
the festival of melbourne my management
in london
cowered
to what they thought public opinion was
as it turned out people thought it was
hilarious we'd seen it but they worried
people got fired of the network i heard
and it became it became a negative thing
which is now if it happened because of
social media i'd be huge because of that
it would have had me i would have toured
the world but at the time
and because the australians honestly
in media are a bit homophobic because
they really were then it's like why is
the gay man in the room the smartest one
with all the power how did that happen
it's also complicated too because the
show's host was a famously closet case
and didn't want his image soiled
or associated with in any way the gay
community there's a lot of [ __ ] going on
that's something that i've noticed i did
a talk at the start of the year and part
way through it there was um a couple of
emails that got sent to the group that
were organizing it that said uh have you
seen this have you seen what chris has
been talking about and it was a link to
a trailer on my instagram of me and
douglas murray and douglas was talking
about the chas chop autonomous zone and
saying just being douglas right talking
about it i don't talk throughout the
entire trailer i don't say anything but
i do laugh and they said that this laugh
is
we're taking this laugh as the fact that
he is agreeing this is a signal that
he's agreeing with what douglas says are
you really inviting this person so when
that happened first off this is the
indignation right you think this is
absolutely insane
you know douglas's points are his own i
was laughing it's my show it's a trailer
from eight months ago the only reason
that this would have been sent in by
multiple people remembering it's a
really old trailer is if it's a
coordination on their part to get
multiple people to send it in so on and
so forth but for a moment
i saw in that situation
oh this could be this could be my thing
this could be
cancelled for a laugh this could be this
is how i this is how i could get myself
on to took a call so no this is how i
could get myself you know you do the
tour off the back of it you get the
right people to retweet it and you
notice this the opportunity arising this
could be my evergreen state for brett
weinstein or my bill c-16 for jordan
peterson
something
innocuous that that ends up blowing up
in somebody's face and that that like i
didn't follow through with it they said
look don't antagonize anyone don't reply
on twitter sure enough the whole thing
dissipated went away did the talk it's
absolutely fine but
for a moment i saw in the less gracious
part of my nature a bit rise up and say
this could be
this could be the beginning now and the
same way that we have perverse
incentives i think for potentially some
people that are involved in cases as
jurors or as judges or as whatever the
lawyers um i think that you have this
with cancellation now that some people
almost go out of their way like
cancellations the new love island if you
manage to get cancelled somewhere not
sufficiently bad that the public hates
you but bad enough to garner a little
bit of attention that's your springboard
to a career
as long as you're in a kitty fiddling
anything else people will
come out and see you i think
and
yeah i think it's the only way
to sell papers now to put bad news on
the front of them
and badness becomes good because
suddenly you recognize but they've said
for a long time right any publicity is
good publicity i think harvey fierstein
was criticized for saying that decades
ago uh during the aids crisis that any
publicity
for gay men is good because it gets us
out there
and makes us more real
i think it was harvey
but either way
that's i think always been the case and
now
it doesn't take
a
a media facility like a newspaper or a
network to promote it you can do it out
of your home
i just feel like though
he laughed how dare he it's like
it makes
i just did a show at a very kind of uh
upscale kind of area on saturday night
uh the wine country here and it was sort
of and um beautiful little room a
tasting room and it's a comedy show
there the staff are great very
supportive but the audience were just so
clammed up like a lot of very if the
whole room was white except for one
black guy he was enjoying it but the
rest of the room were a lot of like 20
to 35 year old white women with their
arms crossed just very anxious about
just about everything i said on stage
now i've been doing this for quite a
while and if you pay to come see me you
kind of know what you're in for i mean
i'm just surprised it's the same old
[ __ ] rehashed every [ __ ] hype is how
i am that's my act so it but but they're
getting more just more
about
everything which makes me poke and prod
and the more they restrict the more i
push you know so at the end
a bunch of people have we really enjoyed
it i've said you might reflect that in
your response next time then and i might
think about coming back
because i
i'm not here to be your sounding board
to see if it's okay if you laugh at this
and then laugh at it in the car on the
way home i don't want to be a part of
that conversation i want the
conversation in the room but one thing
that i find
with all that's going on around us with
social media and people being terrified
of being caught on camera responding
like you just said
is that immediate response
is stifled
so i'm terrified about people not
actually telling me what they think it
really [ __ ] freaks me out oh so
they've got a public persona and a
private persona
and to think that you're gonna leave the
room and that suddenly what people
actually think about you is going to be
voice i [ __ ] hate that it's why i
never talk
negatively about comedians people i work
with there's no point in it anyway it's
not going to get you anywhere but i
don't if i feel badly about somebody
i'll just tell them
i never want to be that person leaving
the room that becomes a kind of you know
a burden
oh it just [ __ ] freaks me out so
here's an interesting element of that
from my industry which is nightlife and
when i first started doing club nights
and my first ever event was a big bar
crawl where people would buy a t-shirt
and your t-shirt was your ticket and
there was tasks on the back like pull a
pig get off with three randoms uh down a
drink with somebody that you don't know
like get a piggy back from one venue to
another blah blah blah and people used
to write on the inside of their arms the
first half of the alphabet and the
second half of the alphabet and you have
to tick off the letters of the first
name of the person that you'd kissed and
you know you're running around at the
end of the night trying to find azara or
something and
um i wondered i never thought about it i
had a conversation with a buddy who did
the same thing as me the same franchise
but down south listen where's that
culture gone where's that kind of
sloppy
very very casual transactional
physical relationship [ __ ] gone for 18
to 21 year olds specifically in the uk
but maybe in the us as well and he said
his idea was that because of the advent
of smartphones no one can ever do
anything in public that's private
anymore you can never get off you can
never pull a pig on a bar crawl without
five videos of that now haunting you for
the remainder of your days that's going
to be with you if you decide to do
something and that's caused people to
have far more scruples about how they
behave publicly that was his idea and
that i don't know if it's true but it
[ __ ] makes a lot of sense it does
i think you know
no one can wake up and say i don't
remember what happened last night
anymore because similar whole camera do
you see this this is exactly what
happened yeah exactly
so you can't have a hangover and forget
about it
and i think
you know that makes people
like this this kid this trial that's
going on
uh right down the us about this
um african american man who was hunted
down by two white guys and burned in the
street you know
the people they don't just have
witnesses because witnesses are tricky
and you know trials can never really
trust witnesses because people see all
sorts of things differently but a lot of
it's on film
so the guys themselves filmed it it's
why you know hitler's still with us you
know the big h is just so popular
because it was really the first
kind of fashion it was a fascist revival
but really the first
international battle that was filmed the
wars before that
were not so sure
but hitler put everything on cinema
and um
that's why he's still such a big draw i
think
and so people see all that and think you
know gotta i gotta keep my job
and i can't keep my job if they see me
to you described because so much of it
can be like also what you said can be
perceived
as as less casual and less fun and
flirtatious but you can perceive it as
being
misogynistic or racist so you've got to
be careful interpretation's always open
like that right
i mean no one can say i mean
there's so many things that people feel
they can't reveal about themselves
because it might like
it might be seen as a preference which
is racism
right
if every preference you're racist right
away
so you got to be careful
i mean
i don't have these boundaries
in in the way that i work and what i do
on stage
but i certainly don't
there's a few things i won't say anymore
i never thought i'd say that but it's
true
for too long
well i don't drop the n bomb on stage
anymore i used to and there's a purpose
behind it and i don't drop the p-bomb
anymore
because
you'll just lose them for too long
before you lose them for about 30
seconds and then they recover
and i could manage that but now
they'll just completely stop listening
so there's no point talking about rogan
he's got a new bit in his stand-up show
where he's talking about why he'll still
use the word [ __ ] but he won't use the
n-word and he's talking about it for
ages and going back and forth and they
say what is it about the word retards
that means that you will say it and
about the n word that means that you
won't he says it's because i'm a lot
more scared of black people than i am of
retards
it's a great lie yeah
um
it's so wrong and i i'm talking about
right now why my husband wants to he he
talks about having children all the time
and i talk about how i only want to
downs i only want a downey if i'm gonna
have a kid i want to be a [ __ ] and so
i think i
i escaped usually we're [ __ ] that
bit because if i do
the the the
the empathy i'm trying to put forward i
lose it
but if you have a good joke about look
when i teach a comedy course i do in
london sometimes um in isla in um stoke
newington
um when i try to find funny people in
that area comedy course to them i do ask
them and i've been told to do this by
other comics one good
challenge is to ask them to write a rape
joke first thing they should do write a
rape joke because they're hard to write
but if you learn to write a good one
that's great i've got about 30 in my act
and i still tell them but because
they're good
and i got to kill time um
but i'm not going to kill rape because
it's a money maker and if you can write
a
brilliant one great and there is still
an audience that wants to laugh and
there's still an audience that wants to
write those letters on their arms and
there's still an audience that wants to
have a couple of drinks and do something
they can forget about and that's i think
the majority of us and when i talk to
people in britain or audience members
when i stay after and chat with them i'm
relieved and it re rely it
it i find it restorative for what i do
because
they just want to have a good time
you know
there's so many reasons for me to be
nervous about performing in front of say
um army navy guys who go to the comedy
store a lot in london
on their time off
because the army in the navy in the uk
and the us have this image of how they
are right which might not be inviting to
someone like me not just gay but
american and
flamboyant and flirty on stage and dirty
and unnecessary you know nauseating
but when i talk to those guys after
they're like you are perfect we'd love
to have you so many times
you we would love to i'm like even
within my accent they're like we love
americans when the american soldiers
show up it's a party you would kill and
crete you would kill in cyprus but then
i call these companies to book me and
they're they just what they just will
not they won't want to
they don't want americans they don't
want gay men they don't want some they
don't want someone my age they want
someone white there's so many reasons to
not book me you know
and i if i only talked to industry
people in my business i would quit
but the audience is great
gay man's the new white man that's the
problem
well i think you know i think the gay
thing is now normalized and that's why i
can't get away with as much as far as
people concern on stage because we're
not naughty anymore yeah just like you
yeah well douglas douglas had this bit
from the madness of crowds where he said
you know that your minority has been
completely assimilated into a culture
when you have to put up with the same
level as [ __ ] of everybody else
yeah it's true
yeah i mean believe me the stuff i used
to get away with on stage it's more
difficult though which makes it more
appealing to me like how to find a way
because that's always been the challenge
of stand-up is is to be relevant
and it doesn't mean because you're older
that you can't be and i don't think an
audience thinks when i walk in the stage
always old i don't listen to this so a
couple of young people might think he's
a dinosaur but i don't think they do i
think again they just want to enjoy
themselves so it's up to us to make our
language accessible but that's always
been the case to make a story from a
stranger make sense in front of a room
full of strangers
so that's what we have to do when when
comics complain oh they're too dummies
they're just so woke or we're being
cancelled or you can't say it's like no
no no
you need to find a way to make your act
accessible they've paid it's not their
job to dissect your act to make it funny
that's up to you so
scott kapoor ladies and gentlemen if
people want to keep up to date with
whatever you're doing or harass you
online where should they go
my website it's all about me me me so
all the information is there it's just
my name skepticbro.com listen thanks for
calling it's great to see you i know
wait austin it's been really fun to do
this i forgot that we were doing it and
then i remembered how much i wanted to
and i'm really glad we did me too man me
too uh when are you back in the uk are
you back anytime soon january 19th my
husband's craving to get back he is so
sick of this country
um yeah so we're gonna yeah january 19th
but and i'll see you there yes you will
do and uh thanksgiving enjoy
thanksgiving tomorrow well thank you too
are you stuffing anything or are you
going to be waiting come on we've
managed to we've managed are you cooking
anything are you no of course not i've
got i'm just yeah i'm just i'm turning
up i'm the
i don't know what i am i'm the token
brit at the time if you want to learn
how to the turkey it's so fun
it's about you feel like are you doing
it are you doing it tomorrow oh yes so
easy to do you make the stuffing in 10
minutes you shove it in you put in the
oven and you leave it you don't you
never open the oven again and four hours
later it pops out and people are so
impressed you've done
almost nothing
it's great i'll have to read i'll
facetime you tomorrow if i'm struggling
all right let me know catch you later
cranberry sauce
have a great one thank you chris nice to
see you what's happening people thank
you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace